how's it going guys welcome back to
cmake this is
episode six of basically how to use
cmake
now uh take note that i'm running on
linux uh you might
you probably already know that you've
seen the previous versions but now i'm
going to talk about
installing your actual software so you
build software it does a little thing
and now you want people to just be able
to use it like they do any other
software rather than having to go to
your directory build it use your all
special
run commands and stuff and they just
want to be able to use it like they
would any other
software so that that's pretty standard
uh so we're looking at installing here
now installing is actually quite simple
so we're gonna
as usual open up visual studio code here
you can use whatever you want
i'm just keeping it simple that way and
what we're going to do here
is we need to look at installing the
files for
our like our main executable and for any
libraries we build
so we take our well let's start with the
library
so let's look at our adder library that
we've been playing around with as a demo
library and
look at the cmakelist.txt and before it
was just this line
now we're just adding these lines so
we're adding install
the targets is the library name there
and the destination
is where you want it to go and live is
pretty standard there and
install files and this is the dot h file
because uh you're gonna need to see that
your program is going to need that
destination include so that's it just
those two lines
on your library and now let's go to the
top level cmakelist.txt file
and we're going to add just two lines to
the bottom of that as well
and here they are once again install
targets
your project name uh of course which is
going to resolve to whatever this is
it's just olas in our case
trying to make a meme out of it here uh
destination
bin so ben is where
this uh runnable file goes
and then install files and we want that
config file
that has our version and library stuff
and we are using project binary dir
slash alaska pic.h so that's where
and we're putting quotes around that i
think it's it'll probably work without
it
but since this resolves to a string we
just want to make sure
and destination include on that dot h
file
so now what we do is we just
redo our configure and our configure of
course is just
this command in command line
these little hd things are optional of
course but we do need to tell where the
source is
and where to build to so i'm just going
to run that
and i'm doing it like so
and all that does is just run that
command line same as just paste it in
there
and then we want to build it again
builds fine and of course previously to
run it we would have to go
into the build directory
and then dot slash and then this whole
thing and that runs it
there we go but now
so if i just go let me go back here
if i just want to be able to run it from
anywhere in my command line just like so
it says not found but if we want to run
it like like cmake does you just type
this and it runs cmake right
so we want the same thing to happen here
that's kind of the end goal
and now that we have those install
things put in here cmake will handle
that for us all we have to do
actually i think it's already done it uh
now a tricky thing it depends on your
version of cmake here
so let me just real quick before i let's
let's look at our cmake version
because one of the things i was noticing
is
well i'll just paste this in here i
guess that will make it easy
okay so this is what it says oh there's
no word wrapping
i'll just return a few times i know this
is really ghetto
okay run the cmake executable of course
you make gui to configure and build it
with your chosen build tool so we did
that right
and it says run the install step by
using the install option in the cmake
command
which was introduced in 3.15 but as you
can see we're using
cmake 3.13 so that's not going to work
for us so if you're using 3.15
you can do it with the install option on
the cma command
there's more about that all over their
website here's a quick look at it
it's basically this some stuff here
but so we're going to do it the optional
way
of or it says or build the install from
your id
this will install appropriate header
files libraries executables
so we have to do it with make install
instead is basically the point
yeah we're gonna have to run make
install
so whereas before when we ran
like to build it where's our build here
we just change directory to out build
and then run make
and that builds it but if we run make
install
that'll copy the files to where we want
them to go
but we don't want to do that on the
build necessarily so i just made another
sh file for that just goes to that
directory and runs make install
so let's go ahead and do that so just a
quick example before
this doesn't work but if we run that
install now oops
install dot sh
that i created already ch modded and
everything
it does this oh it does build it first
of all
it's already built it's fine then it
says install configuration there's no
install config we didn't add anything
special
now what we get here is a cmake error
see make install 47
file install cannot copy file
and this is our executable out build the
last two
user bin oblasts it cannot copy it right
cannot so if we try to run it it says
still not found
so basically what we got to do is we
just have to sudo
before running this command
and then it seems to do it okay so it
installs it successful in that we we
still have an error here i couldn't
figure this out
so maybe i'll leave this to the comments
if someone can figure this out bonus
points i'll give you a give you a heart
whatever
all that good stuff so at the cma
install cannot file install cannot find
this olas config.h i'm not sure why it
can't find this it should be able to
find this
it's there because if we go to out
build it's right there so i'm a little
confused
as to why oh i spelled it wrong i'm a
noob
never mind no heart for you i figured it
out already
so i bet in here yeah we just put
an extra c in here like a like a total
noob
so now we should be able to do it and uh
we'll have to super user
of course and there we go now it seems
happy it gives us the whole thing
installing installing it put it put in
the glfw stuff that we wanted
because that's what we require and all
our other
libraries they're all installed so now
it doesn't matter where we are
i'll just change directory to my root
home here
anytime we just type this in the command
line it just runs our app
so you can do that within your app so
you can just get them installed or if
you're
giving it to a buddy or whatever they
can just install it
and then it just you can just run it
like a normal app like you could
anything else like you could cmake like
you could
uh awk or anything you just type in the
command line
so that's how you do it and also i
should note if you're uh
let's see i'll bring this over while i
talk about it real quick
this installs to user local on unix and
c program files and project name on
windows
so there you go
on windows it goes right your program
files unix using your local list doesn't
talk about mac
don't know why but i'm sure it goes to
the default location there
so just real quick let's uh let's change
directory a little bit go back a few
and we can now go you know
we're deep on the unix stuff we'll go to
user local where it said
and we'll check that out and we see ben
we see live we see
include so we can look at those if we
look at our bin for example
we'll see that it now has that file
there
and same with the others oops
so let's just take a look at include and
see what we got there
and we got our adder we got the glfww
stuff that are required and we got the
we got that as well and we can also look
at
our live and we should see all the lives
that we installed some of these were
already here from other stuff but
there's our live adder there's our live
glw3
so it just that's how it just finds it
when you run it it just
has them ready to go there
so i think that is it i'm not sure if i
missed anything or not
let me know down below if you get
confused a super quick recap
there's that
there's that one in our live
and you just of course do configure and
build as before and then you just run
the install at the
at the end to get that install going all
right guys hope you enjoyed this episode
i'll see you next one peace out